yeah that's that's small fry
it's in double tap but wait that doesn't
make any sense
uh
so
hello hello everybody
all right
sorry for the delay but we're here we're
live my download was like taking a
little while but
so far from what i've seen everybody
else's dreams everybody's good to go so
it looks like it was amazing this time
around
um hope everyone is doing well brand new
season of apex legends going down today
i'm going to be playing with jordan and
my buddy jeremiah and you guys know
jordan picking up movement hi guys
[Music]
from the discord hello i'm like oh my
god hello hello i'm just voice like the
voice of god
all right so we're gonna try to
literally jump right in
check out this new map check out ash
hello chad hello everyone yo brandon
what's good
who else is still waiting update well if
you were having issues on steam i
literally
had to like pause the download because
it was stuck on like a hundred percent
for like 45 minutes so i you're right
it's double cap and crafting what the
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
my head's in the clouds
yeah i'm ready for this i'm so ready for
this i am extremely ready for this
are we ready
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
not you guys
let's go
to
fish farms wasn't super exciting i was
hoping there'd be fish but there weren't
any fish
let's go to the mill
[Music]
you're just throwing out words and you
expect me to know what they mean
copy the map is massive look at this
yeah it's
huge this is the best part
but it will be back
okay
all right let me know if that's a little
bit better
sometimes say apex audio is just super
loud and sometimes crazy though
oh oh
well aren't you fancy
it's also blue
oh a car
and another blue shield here i need one
of those
how nice
so for everyone in chat who might not be
aware this is like the biggest map
to date it's 15
larger than world's edge
which is honestly terrifying stabilizer
here
level two yeah
level two
and it's playable space too which is
just wild exactly
um let me know if you see a car anywhere
so i can switch to it
new weapon the car smg
you can switch between light and heavy
ammo and attachments
my rng is pretty bad so like
usually getting good loot on drop is
like not my forte extended light mag so
the car is going to help me out assuming
i can find one
this is a real
it's a real thing yeah the car is a lot
of fun it uh it doesn't care which if
you have light mag or heavy mag it gives
you max no matter what so if you have
only light ammo but you have a heavy mag
it doesn't care it treats it as if it's
a max light mag
it's very cool
very excited
there's also prowler nests oh as i say
there's crawlers nearby
oh good a heavy mag my prowler is
actually complicated
someone already got a 20 bomb 4k with
ash well you know i'm not surprised i'm
really not 50 left i feel like
everyone's so good at this game
like how did all of you simultaneous
simultaneously get so good at this game
persia persia
car smg oh yeah oh sorry i was reading
chat
i know
i'm able to run
all right oh yeah
oh my goodness
easy
probably nest cleared oh okay giving my
shield to recharge no don't heal just
crapped it back to pull there's the crap
yeah the big brain what do you need
double tap
flat line's slow better than car i do
love me a flat line i'm not gonna lie
the flat one right over here
pretty cute
i'm getting like a little bit of
stuttering
crafting scared that once i get into a
fight later i just gotta patch myself up
oh my friends are just gonna be
even worse i have a glitch where uh
valkyrie's uh
jet controls aren't disappearing on her
hands so she's still holding them while
i'm holding a gun
very busy yeah they definitely changed
the bunch of crafting costs for stuff
now oh my camera is not
focusing
i think it's some focusing on this thing
gotta hop up here
double tap trigger why why does this
exist
and it's not on the floor anymore the
scout is no longer on the floor everyone
yeah very good
well you know it'll be our mascot
and i will take this peacekeeper
how are half the squads dead already the
map is so big i don't understand
a lot of people went for
the blue zone antenna i think it was so
i think they just all killed each other
like just right at the start
everybody landed fragment already
oh i can see where people dying oh wait
i'm ash
sorry yeah
i forgot i keep thinking on valk i've
been mating her like so much the past
couple months that i just forget
yeah they're pretty far they're like oh
they were like over here
[Laughter]
double double tap quadruple tap hmm
oh someone just used a daunter i think
if they flash when people use them like
way over there
or maybe they just naturally flash
ignore me this is new for me
i don't know how anything works
i don't know if they have this map
really makes me want to play
goldberg
oh my goodness
i'll take the
right in the chest as they got 14 kills
on their first game all right i'm gonna
channel the energy of ryan in the chat
and oh there's not even 14 people oh
there there's not even 14 people for me
okay i've made a grave oh okay i'm
panicking i was actually trying to use
my old it didn't work
i'm running and i am lagging like i
thought i was going to
i gotta jump scared i think they're in
the southeast on this bridge
yeah
one's over there
oh no you don't have your purple
shoulders
know i wasn't prepared for that i was
like looking at chat
well
i at least almost did a hundred damage
i did like a whole tin i swear
the whole 10 damage like in
literally a whole 10 damage uh i have to
reinvite you
oh you guys are disconnected right
there you go
all right back at it
your bun they took olympus off rotation
yeah i like olympus too i'm not gonna
lie i do enjoy that map
um i don't really use the alc settings
because they're pretty complicated
and i'm just like i just want to run
around
okay
i'm gonna be annoyed every single time i
see this screen pop up and i see double
tap and crafting rotation i wonder if
they meant to put the other new hop up
and that one got in or something i don't
know oh that's definitely possible
because that one also is like doubling
or it's like dual something
the watson books are pretty cool
i mean i never really played her back
when she was really a meta but
i think
they definitely have some
character specific lines
between her and
[Music]
all this horizons
stuff
the maps in rotation are world's edge
and
um the new map storm point but i think
for the first whole week it's going to
be stern point and then
because i'm talking to the chat jordan
you have to you have to fly us somewhere
that sounds nice this time of year i
like the spot first
the g7
is indeed in the care package no longer
on the floor and it has double tap and
it does more damage
i'm glad it's in the care package i
don't want to get beamed by that gun
oh we got friends oh we got people on
our wall
oh
i don't think i landed in an optimal
place unfortunately
oh cool the bow check i love that one
all right i got a mozambique and a
triple take
we're a set the troop will take back and
ground luke
the best shotgun in the game
i hear a mirage right next to me all
right where are you
crack one in the bug
opening fire reloading
under fire oh my goodness
damn it
[Music]
all right that was good so good
you got this jeremiah you're better
all right that's heather
definitely good for those close quarter
fights like that
honestly it took me way too long to
realize i was stuttered i should have
turned around and kept fighting but i
have to restart because it keeps
disconnecting me okay and i'm
reconnecting really fast which is nice
but
it's not very conducive to like winning
we'll open up a single apex pack while
we wait
damn no heirloom a new car you hate to
see it i have 38
apex packs
i'll open one for chat
yay there could literally be a new car
in there i got nothing but common items
oh wait no i got two rares all right
crafting materials hey
i can always use some crafting materials
i gotta buy a bunch of stuff for ash
assuming you're gonna main her i
probably won't mean her she's
not quite my piece i've been definitely
having a lot of fun with valk i just
think her movement is
better for my style
hello welcome back want to be 80s
there's still um tridents around the map
for sure i think that
they're probably not as uh you probably
won't see them as much because the
gravity cannons are on and
that's the new the new goods the new
cool stuff
this is a legendary item
oh snap what'd you get
god damn it it was the legendary emote
for pathfinder
oh that one's cute i don't use
pathfinder
i did want to unlock
this really cute
skin
the pastel one look how adorable that is
i won't
yeah
i'm up to 58 pickaxe
why are you not opening it
i mean i tried to do like i was like oh
i'm gonna do a pack opening it's gonna
be so fun and then like i opened five
and got bored so it takes a long time
in there
i don't stress my rng
i think i'm up to
four heirlooms now
that's a lot
i have none oh snap i'm seeing some
watson memes in the chat
also bloodhound mirage bangalore watson
that's a
very
very unique
selection of characters you got there
honestly all i can think about with some
of the areas of this map is like whose
town takeover is coming next because
there's plenty of space everyone can
have some real estate here
i'm going to play as general griezmann
let's put things together there is water
party boat could take a return
all right just gotta repair it from
party crashers snap and fly over here
i mean surely he got like surely yes it
was insured right like maybe you think
mirage bought insurance no you think
garage bought insurance
fish farms
right it all looks
oh my goodness you stuck me
ow ow ow
i'm really far from you guys
i guess
broke ass
and
he's like chasing me
[Applause]
and someone's been behind me this entire
time
right here in the center
oh my goodness
oh dear all right well maybe i should
have turned and fought that other theme
i was trying to get back to you guys
[Music]
i'm curious
because i feel like most of the
takeovers have involved like the
character's
kit ability
wait which one's you oh the bottom one
says
take over would be like you would press
a button and it would call him just a
giant air strike with like a few bubbles
would pop up and you'd have to like get
in like one of them to
protect yourself
stressful but yeah like a lot of fun at
the same time
dang
everyone would know if you were at that
town takeover
i mean it wouldn't be any different from
using like crypto's map room where it's
like oh i hear a giant pulse going
across the entirety of king's canyon
someone must be at crypto's place
what if it just called in an airstrike
over where everyone was located
they had to move but you were like in
one building like survey camp
yeah win that would be horrible imagine
how many random kills you get
if you just third party at like five
different parties that one
with that
clear your mind
don't let me make games guys please
they're all gonna be way broken
this is your champion all right i need
to remember to throw
the ark tether
i need to remember to do that
because
yeah
i'm a controller player i'm great up
close i just need to run into their face
tether them and then let amos get
through the rest
all right i'm ready it's easy easy
well i've been doing it all wrong maybe
not good after all considering
everyone
eventually
except for me
yeah i feel like this map is so big that
people just get impatient halfway
through in the ship and they're like
whatever yeah let's just get out of here
and then there's like this is fine
where's that oh there is more out there
jesus this place is huge yeah like where
does this launcher even go
you know every time there's a new map
you always have to go through this the
era of like where the thing spawn
like which corner of this building is
loot spawning in
we're so far from everyone though
first i have a turbocharger by the way
let's take the gravity cannon
oh wait that's going in the wrong
direction
there's a car
activating
can i drive this through the gravity
cannon wait i think i can
i'd be disappointed if you couldn't i
know
there's definitely enough space
oh
i was like maybe i could drive it
through when it opens
it was worth a shot
that was totally for science guys
and i have nothing
oh i have an rna9 they aren't
this map is pretty but i'm not going to
lie there's so much foliage and greenery
that
i can't see anything
my eyes oh
oh yeah they're going around behind you
i got lasered he's right here in the
water to your left
oh wait
oh i'm so bad in this game
we just need to land at one spot that
has really good loot and then have
enough time to loot it
yeah i feel like
that's a brilliant plan
i feel like this map's gonna require me
to be a lot more impatient and i don't
usually like to play that way
like i occupation
want to run in
and you're either going to live and
you're going to die
[Music]
how it is
all right let's open another pack
oh we'll never know what's in it
yeah i think that
ash has good utilities but
yeah like i said she's just gonna
require to be more patient like she
doesn't really have an escape like that
unless she has her oats
but then it's like
kind of want to use it
optimally
but hey i mean i was like solo octane
jump pad if you get away before so
that's pretty much like the same thing
we're going to do beautiful things
together i don't know why while i was
using revenant that we didn't use the
strategy that i wrote about i know right
did you even have it
right we were running around yeah
you all when i see you
it's okay
we got this oh wait you're not revving
it anymore
no i'll do it next time
begins may the goats bless you
can you feel this beast it's like you
can fall off in between these little
crevices here
mental note so that hopefully
i don't fall off crashing the fire
he's just taking a nap
[Music]
oh that is not a door
um
all right well
i uh
i'm probably gonna die but i don't know
i've been caught
hold the line i'm honestly so low i'm
down two of them but ash is still up
i think she's on the roof or something
she is
oh it's pathfinder
sorry
there's like a pathfinder floating
around near you guys i am also bad guys
thank you
there's someone in the corner right
there
yeah that's true
[Applause]
oh
i actually haven't played
apex on console in a really long time i
actually used to play on ps4 for a while
when the game first came out
and then i switch over to pc like
a couple of years ago or like a year and
a half ago or so
seen pro over here
i mean i don't use mnk i still use my
controller on pc but it does feel faster
than playing on console that was like
the biggest thing i noticed when i
switch over your pc i was like man like
everything just feels faster but
probably because of you know frames and
all that jazz
those frames
those frames though
all right let's see
it's tough with a map this big to be
like all right i want to land
somewhere
and like figure out where all the stuff
is so that when i'm landing i can
actually go get good food but then you
want to see all the pois and you're like
it's gonna take me so long yeah i wish
that we've landed
yeah we've landed at five separate
locations and never once traveled back
to a location that we traveled to in an
earlier game like i don't know how any
of these places connect to each other
yeah
this snap is going to take some time
i thought like sticking with your team
was important before i feel like i don't
have to pull another video
[Applause]
okay
i need to get one kill with ash i
remembered to throw my tether that time
although i don't think it hit pathfinder
i was kind of
doing it out of panic
i say the second you remember what the
tether does you just remember to not run
away yeah
it loses all of its effectiveness
yeah exactly that sounds like the ass
tried to tether me and i'm like wait a
second just don't stim as octane i just
turned and down here i'm like okay
i think that is cool though like putting
people in a situation where like you
have to fight me you have to fight me
you can't run
that's cool
i imagine
in comp when there's like
teams still in ring five
there's going to be just ash tethers
everywhere no one's going anywhere
i really hope
no one's going with us but we have three
squads landing at the landmark next to
us
next is in quotation marks like
[Applause]
that i was like wow someone must be here
oh boosted loader it's in the voice file
oh nice
helmet
am i the best person for gold helmet
probably probably all right
why is this place so big i know
we're not
too far from that poi there's a zip line
that goes right up to it if we want to
go flip it out
uh let me alt here really quick
stop mowing the grass outside damn it
they were like oh jordan is doing
something that requires audio
get the lawnmower
standard stock and barrel stabilizer
daddy like
mama's got you now wait is that the only
backpack
yep
i want to see if i can try to use my
passive
i see anyone in that well see if
anyone's dead yeah i'm just like
literally looking at the poi
on the map
one minute until the ring no that wasn't
over here
see that's pretty good too actually like
you hear fighting in the town over and
you want to confirm if they killed the
team or if that was another fight
somewhere else oh yeah mm-hmm all right
we're going up
45 seconds
can you reach the ring in that time
[Applause]
oh no someone was inside
ouch
behind you ready
[Music]
[Music]
yo discussions what is good
welcome to the stream
we are running around new maps
checking out how massive it is
why'd they get triple take energy ammo
we're going back in time now you know
we're revisiting the roots of the triple
take this season
is it wild to think that there are
people playing this game that did not
know that the triple take was once an
energy ammo sniper rifle this game is a
completely new game
like if you think about this game
compared to the state it was in when it
first launched oh my goodness
why is double tap in crafting
it's gotta be
how else will you get it for your guns i
don't understand
it was just to remind you that it exists
again
even though you can't put it on anything
it's a feature not a book
you know got a couple of extra materials
you know it's a souvenir really
[Music]
and paying attention to the maps we can
find you know what we we should have
been bigger brain last game and waited
until we saw
one of the teams die yeah and then go up
there
that's that's not using your passive
ability
well
to look at when someone actually dies
like you have to open your map or like
they have to be within your mini map
range right so that poi was a little bit
too far to see in my mini map
but we could have just like gone
underneath yeah
waited like the ten more seconds for my
alt to charge use it and then teleport
it up with yours and we gotta expand our
minds
i don't know what server i'm on actually
am i getting pocket last night
okay several friends
um you don't sound sorry
i don't know where to go for loot uh
there's definitely people over on the
west side
first blood is ours
oh this is right here
oh
right next to you girl
[Music]
they might start fighting each other
yeah
there is all kinds of havoc going on i'm
crawling as fast as i can
deploy
them
did you see me just straight up
like she expects to fly
isn't over get up
right next to me
but you're a medic you're a medic that's
a war crime
unbelievable but you have kills now you
have kills on your track
dude oh do i oh yeah that watson died
let's go
two kills
um
you know
i tried that was uh
almost
i just did not have the resources for
that unfortunately
is ash good i think
she will be as good as the player allows
her to be i feel like she's going to be
easy to make mistakes with because
like you saw right there i was like
trying to get somewhere safe but i ended
up running too far and i had no way to
get back to my team until it was too
late like that's
that's unfortunate
but that doesn't mean
just means you have to play more
mindfully like what the characters
capabilities are that's why i play a lot
of movement based champions so that are
as movement-based legends so that
that can kind of make up for that for me
for example valk or like a pathfinder
[ __ ] or something like that but
i think she is good for those close
range fights when you're like
jumping on a team and like trying a
third party like throw your old maybe
combo your all even though we
didn't
we'll do it we'll do it we will do it
she's certainly no
season 10 first two weeks here
right right like she's not just gonna
naturally
make you better
whereas like some of the on launch
legends they just kind of naturally made
you better because they're a lot
stronger i don't think she's gonna lose
i see two other flaws landing with us
but honestly shout outs to progress
right because
launching was a balanced life thing is
not easy what if we just launched it
over there
oh no okay a chat look away i have a 30
30 and i can't promise you anything
at a 30 30 so good
but i am not jordan you must understand
my limitations
i'm an automatic gun girls allah
see now yeah i can see on the they
definitely done killed that whole team
but now we can run over there and scan
the boxes
unless they come over here
or they're finding something else
they would never take off
i picked up an l star earlier expecting
to dominate for getting that first
i just got sniped by a peacekeeper
all right bangalore
they're juking me
over here i think enemy's there
yep
right here is back
yeah
good job i just got panned by bloodhound
oh no
oh my goodness
taking fire
i know my camera keeps on focusing it's
like focusing on the spine
i wonder how much further i could have
thrown my [ __ ] actually
i don't know if that was actually the
furthest i could have thrown it
it's rough going from like
playing a champion like valik everyday
to someone who is strictly on the ground
yeah why
i'm like oh man
yeah it's like switching from creative
to survival and minecraft and you're
like
yeah i become abruptly aware of like how
bad my movement is when i can't just fly
over like a wall and be
i have definitely jumped to my death
numerous times in olympus thinking that
i was playing as valkyrie and being like
oh i'm gonna flank these people and i
just jump off the edge prepared to fly
i'm like ah [ __ ] i'm steer this is not
gonna work the way that i thought it was
there is a new weapon
the car i can see i'll try to pick it up
it's so good
like i used it only once but it like
tore through someone's shield
yes
got like the chalk outline
this is your champion
[Music]
uh let's go to gale station this might
be a good place to land but what do i
know
wait have we gone in this place already
yeah we went there once oh let's go to
antenna
follow the leader that's me it looks
like a smaller version
[Music]
uh
hello friends
oh that's a lifeline we don't have a
lifeline in the squad
that's an ass but it's not my ass
lots to think about
oh
neither of which
[Applause]
i
am so far away all right hold up
they're big fighters down there though
can i even get across there from here i
got one camera
last guy just kind of you know dropped
oh there's a okay there's a zip line
down there
there's people down here
shooting that guy's flush nice there's
another one down here
okay
yes
she jumped back down eliminate the
energy where'd she go she jumped down
she's just
she's over there
right there right there she's looking at
us
why do i have this gun
[Music]
[Music]
jeremiah we're out of here oh wait
or are we
or are we
to give us an edge okay that was
absolutely god awful that was
well chat if you want to learn how to
not use that that is exactly how you
don't use them
i'm under fire oh and running up this
thing takes 10 million years oh god
please climb oh i can't climb that all
right all right
getting out of this thing without the
zipline
is really hard yeah
looking at this poi i'm like man
valkyrie and horizon are gonna kill
right here
oh no oh i can't see anything
yes it is
yes it's eels
all right this next one has to be my
last one unfortunately okay
as work calls
um
let's take a look at some battle pass
i'm like flabbergasted at how difficult
it was to get out of that little bowl
you couldn't even climb over those
little pipes that were on this
laying around
yeah i'm like
you know chad because because we're
playing for you right now i'm i'm
sticking with ash but best believe
after i'm not shaving anymore and after
i'm off work i'm just kidding we're
using a legend that can fly or something
we just have to
i feel like i could have just flew up
instead of running around all the way to
the side i mean i probably still really
got shot flying up but
running outside of that thing was
horrible
this is your champion
i don't want to kill you but you're in
my way
and there's something
there's only that one zip line too we're
talking about those like these guys
one kills
off there are two squads to the right of
us yeah um well you know we're just
gonna fight him
yeah you know
we're just better
i haven't found a single gun i don't
know what y'all people are talking about
oh i hear them close this is not good
they're in here they're in here our
target is here
i think they turn around
they're running from that other team
opening
oh
[Applause]
oh my gosh
oh my god
goodness gracious oh up top up top stay
around they run
recharge i have to heal
oh no
i'm so tired of giving fortifiedness
i thought that was gonna get taken out
if i could be in here and give you in
here two people in here actually
they're just full healing they're like
going out the door
this door yeah just leave just leave
actually
they don't know you're here no no
they're looking they're looking they're
with me
no because i saw the ash going up i'm
like oh she's
scanning the crypto that i just killed
so
yeah they were just hanging on that door
all right gg
[Music]
one day though one day
it's gonna be great all right goodbye
everybody bye
all right let's see
you could try some duos
maybe
certainly
we can try
if you want uh do you want to switch to
valkyrie so you can have a game but
you're not playing as ash i might play
horizon so we can hear some of the uh
voice lines because they have some like
special voice lines together too the
action hurts that makes sense that makes
sense
also chat i usually play with the music
off so i turned the music on just for
you guys today
turn the music off how dare you yeah you
know i gotta like you know
find my zone and like
i'll try hard when i play
like the music distracts me
oh i forgot to switch wait who was i
thinking wait where is she
all right well
valkyrie is the only one i could find in
time
i swear they moved the character select
screen like one way and my whole brain
is just like what
i don't know what's going on
all right voice lines next turn
i mean
i'm an actual pilot and you're like a
pretend pilot
why not
i don't know where to go wait where is
this i can't even see the people right
ahead like
down gonna be a lot of friends
oh no oh my god
oh
i've made a mistake
um
yeah so i already lost you i don't know
where you went
i saw you
and then ran
i'm trying to run but oh wait i'm back
again i forgot
forgot so soon
yeah we gotta get out of here
that was also for science
just to see how many people
blood imagine crashing and burning on
takeoff
i'm getting a lot of death box markers
behind me
uh-oh safe to touch down we're already
in the next ring
um so i didn't manage to get a gun
i have an re45 with 20 shots
we live though let's go champions out
and i'm just brokenhearted about it
like just being able to do that right
there
it's like
quality of life
brag about it
yay weapons
i feel so armed
[Laughter]
i have a new controller coming soon i'm
so excited because my x button keeps
going out in this one so
looting is
terrible yeah
you only notice it when like you don't
pick up the item on the first go and
it's like ah yes
oh i hear
optics here close range
but they haven't won yet one second good
thing we didn't kill anyone no one can
track us right now
off the radar um i'm not using a scuff
controller i'm actually just using a
regular
xbox series x controller
which is also probably not a good sign
that my x button is already going out
but i use this controller every single
day so
and it's almost been a year now right
since the wear and tear
constantly out of space
i don't know where this goes
but i'm gonna take it
cool
if you fly in here like valkyrie like
you just lose all momentum and like
everything's horrible
just so you guys know
good tip good job
oh there was people here
oh yeah
[Applause]
but no one died
unless i'm just missing all the death
boxes
i still feel like there's at least half
of the pois i haven't even
walked through
yep
why use controller at all um probably a
matter of preference i uh started
playing shooters back in halo so
i'm oh and i just where you are
yes yes i am
but i only saw her i didn't see anyone
else with her i see her in octane i
believe they're like gone gone
i think she's nice safe to touch down
we're already in the next room no i
think they're throwing a nate at someone
else
someone else you say
oh yeah
show me an f-box
abandoned in my sights
wings up
i can't reach the roof
i know
i got one right under me because there's
lots of things
reloading
oh
reloading
[Music]
oh gosh recharging shields
oh [ __ ]
oh name
i think that's something
that's a lot
we got killed so we didn't know
let's go
ash can definitely scan death boxes even
if it's not your teammates so like if
you run into a poi and you see that
there's boxes everywhere i think there
is an eventual like
cool down like it wears off if you wait
too long
um i don't know exactly how long it is
but
it definitely
doesn't last forever i don't think so
yeah we could find out where people are
it might be close maybe four
i wonder if james is working or not one
of our freelancers is playing x right
now
i mean
[Music]
invites
[Applause]
i'll tell you right now though that one
game
was infinitely better than every game i
played with ash simply because i could
move around so much more freely
you little [ __ ] don't say stand by for
free fall
commit
commit to the line
even if we're not in titans i know
legality is jordan that is an ideal
landing place
oh snap alvaro got their first
first match on the new map and they
gotta win feels good
nice good stuff
what did you think of it
it's massive right like holy crap so
many places
no i told chris i'm like i'll write up
like a
impressions thing about
uh the map and i'm like i'm sure i can
explore all of it within like
a few
[Music]
that was like the make or break moment
right there
we're already inside the next ring
oh my goodness there was another team i
think that landed like a little more
right now
i
believe you are correct
anyone who says the triple take is not a
shotgun is just using it correctly yeah
all day
i think i hear them
yeah i think they're right outside the
door
she's jumping down oh gosh
[Music]
i realized way too late that i only had
one shot left in my triple tape so after
breaking the ash i'm like oh i have no
more shots
oh i was literally one shot away from
killing that i watson
rip
anyone else had the graphics glitch i
haven't really had any glitches or bugs
actually which is good
oh did you want to invite uh
oh snap
chad is looking for a one-on-ones who's
gonna take them up on their offer
probably nobody
it's like what is a 1v1 proof in this
game
overall scheme of things
being good at 1v1s and firing range
probably won't help you too much in a
team game
when you have
10 squads in the final ring
no more throwables
um check the store
there's an ash bundle so if you want
the character and this skin
[Music]
and her car skin well i don't know if
it's her car skin it might be kind of
matches her
her whole get up so
i bought the bundle for that car skit
because i'm like oh that skin is dope it
is nice i like it
i'm gonna try to take a look at all the
skins at least
lots of mirage stuff this time
ooh
kind of like that wingman skin
gibraltar
oh the loba edition is live
oh snap
damn
there's a dope skin
which one oh i like that one uh
lobas arms dealer skin
you give me got so many guns and bullets
and stuff like that strapped to her
james is here
oh snap
he says he can knife for a little bit
okay cool yeah i don't think uh
i think which depending on how quickly
we die could be like three or four games
i see he also bought the ash launch
bundle
just bundled up out here look at y'all
all right
sorry for the weight chad
all right james you're a watson main i
totally forgot it
means
in the house
yeah i feel like all the watson mains
are rejoicing this season they're like
buffs
high power weapons low power
how
when you get off work nice nice well
almost through the work day i hope
and then you can hop on
the law large numbers we got this
i feel like i don't know which pois are
like
high tier loot either
yeah
i have no idea
i've come to the acceptance that i'm
going to have a white shield no matter
what
how did watson get her in a balloon i
know
um so watson can place her fences down
instantly pretty much now like she
doesn't have a slow down when she like
gets the fence ready or places it
and
what else
she her ultimate now is has like a
helpful instead of
being on a timer
it charges your shield now
way faster now too which is really good
oh what else
here
backpack here
i know triple take on the ground i'm
happy about that
like why use the mastiff when i can use
a mastiff that has long
range oh i ran right into a wall
i love it
i exited the door and it was just a clip
that's the the only balloon in this
whole map chat right there
everyone else everywhere else has to
rely on the gravity cannons
did bloodhound get any of us i
don't think there were any changes
bloodhelm if i recall correctly
your apex is updating oh i'll snap good
luck oh sorry i'm running like so far
away
because i'm not thinking oh there you go
magazine here
level three
why not take the bowl i'm trying to
use the car a little bit more since it's
the new weapon
and it's pretty
far off and i'm hoping to pick up some
sort of triple ticker sniper as my
second round is done i really want to
carry around two smvs at the same time
i'm gonna take that thing yeah
[Music]
stuck the landing there's at least one
person in here somewhere
yeah i heard
like a frog or something southwest
i think they're out here on the other
side of this ring
oh yeah there's a bunch of death boxes
over there geez oh yeah there's a bandit
out there
a little further 45 on the clock wings
out
pathfinder right under me coming up the
zip right here
he was alone damn confirmed
oh it's just the revenue back up there
yeah there's too many up there
nt
i didn't know there's a team up top too
i thought they were all fighting down
though
did pathfinder get a buff um
no no changes either i think the only
major changes was to watson
and
oops and to um
[Music]
watson and then well new legend ash
doesn't really count as changes
but yeah watson was really the only one
that got any any major changes
which was interesting
make all the crypto main sad
you say all the crypto names as if it's
like
everyone plays this character i feel
like i don't see crypto much at all
sorry chad i'm not accepting any invites
or
anything like that i'm playing matches
with the rest of the game spot crew so
sorry about that but maybe next time
um yeah let's go horizons for black
holes relativity becomes
well
relative
that is a creepy
all right let's go let's do this
let's do this
i'm jump master
bless these jump jets
hmm
here we go too slow let's check out oh
let's go here over there uh oh wait we
went there already i think
that was the place yeah yeah yeah yeah
and ran away immediately
we'll try yeah
right here london's one of us we kind of
died there but
they where we died yeah
perfection
i know we didn't even land yet
that's amazing
we're already inside the next ring
lightning i do not need
it is impossible to forget in your
presence oh
it was watson who did it i thought it
was race who did it
why did i think it was raised who did it
oh there it is
she's like yeah you'll never let me
forget it
all right they're fighting at the mouth
of them
shall we
let's do it
[Music]
i've had no like finding any sights
today which is the
oh they're right here looks like
oh yeah they're behind the things
oh
someone's coming in through the door
body nearby
[Applause]
oh
deployed
she just can't sneak up with her
ability ultimate is just so loud
[Music]
she definitely assholted
james
yeah well she just got the res down
there
yeah
i needed to rush them
i
forgot it was horizon i felt like i
probably would have caught up if i was
valid because i could have threw my
missiles down
volk is just a superior character how
are you
[Laughter]
yo see you later brandon thank you for
tuning in
um they didn't get rid of sniper ammo
but they changed the triple take back to
how it was a long time ago and made it
an energy weapon but it's an energy
marksman weapon now so
you still can pick up like a
sniper stock and stuff
what's the new hop-up the new hop-up is
called a dual shell i think and
basically for the mastiff and the 30-30
when you reload one shell because you
know those weapons are like single fire
or a single
but a bullet reload you get two bullets
instead of one so like you put one shell
in there you get two in the chamber so
that's actually pretty good in my
opinion you're moving
to
there's definitely been times where i
completely ran out and
just like reloading one bullet at a time
and trying to finish off the kill
producing which should be pretty
annoying
they say death catches up to
everyone you can certainly try
all right let's see
there's a prime spot for mayhem
we have a watson this time oh snow
easy boy
are you guys landing over there
i'm landing at my peeing yeah okay
someone's landing on y'all's building
and an octane
it hurts
there's two squads over here i'm running
to you i'm trying to get over there oh
okay okay
[Applause]
and that's the third squad
all right
there's the arthur one up here
first blood game bloody on palace
juice
[Music]
all sights removed from the gate i'm
just kidding
oh someone's close to me out here right
here
i know it's like which one is it gonna
be
i don't know
oh shoot no
oh gosh
i couldn't
i said i was gonna like try to run away
and then i was like oh wait i'm not i
can't just fly to this roof right now
gosh muscle memory please
all right we gotta go back to valve guys
i feel like she's the only viable
character for me
on this map
oh
watson as an
explorer i love that skin
i want to change my my dog's skin
to my uh
the master chief one that is straight up
master chief i don't care anybody says
ever since buying her launch bundle and
equipping her like
viper apex armor i just have not changed
it
true true that skin's pretty good as
well
valkyrie on station ready greg smith you
it's you bro
does look pretty good
i know almighty the triple t i love the
triple take actually i feel like i
didn't appreciate it as much when it was
on the ground last time
and then now like that's back
i have a new appreciation for you
it's so good
i felt like my preference with weapons
has definitely changed so much since i
first started playing
i'm about to look up on the wiki which
poiser hide here
let's make it spicy land here me up
uh-huh
well that might not be too spicy almost
everyone i know everyone's over there
they're all over there
let's land
it's a long trip
you know it's a long trip
like flying the drop ship all the way
across the map
i have no idea if this small building is
better than the tower next to it
maybe it's worse one i think only one
team is here
oh gotta love getting two solves and a
backpack and then
hemlock baby oh my god
that almost scared me i thought i was
gonna die
my rng on weapons has just been so crap
hmm
like i found a three times my triple
take once and i haven't found another oh
[ __ ]
oh no
no they rode up and i was able to damage
them
i love the hemlock i'm just
looking through the iron sights it's
not possible
recharging shields are depleted
[Music]
great
[Music]
i just feel like i can't like
like the second i peek out someone has
like
a gun with long range and a sight on me
every time i can't even see you that far
so i'm constantly like no shields when
they push in it's so bad
all right i think we got time for one
more
one more
uno
not a fan of the new map or ash well
why not
what do you think of it so far that like
is not really like you're fighting with
you know
um
yeah i my game has not crashed
at all since we started playing it took
me a little while to download the update
initially
but after that it's been pretty good our
friend jeremiah was kind of
disconnecting a little bit earlier
but
that was like two times i think but i
haven't crashed at all
and
i don't think jordan's crashed either so
so far so good so far
[Laughter]
now that you've said it out loud i know
now's the time you've jinxed it
i mean honestly
if you think about like last season and
stuff or the previous seasons this is
pretty smooth
mm-hmm
trust me
i know what i'm doing
[Applause]
kyrie valk and the ghost device i don't
know how many of you
play a lot of arenas but like you know
ash is the voice of arenas and
like recently if you go in there and
usually she has like that hologram of
her face in the sensor but now it like
flickers back and forth between ash's
face and dr reed's face
it's really cool all of my fans watching
you know thank you
you all are super into the lord looks
like i'm the jump master
yeah
i've never seen this before
let's go check it out
there's so many spots holy [ __ ]
i think this season is pretty cool so
far because there's a bunch of new stuff
right here's some lovely stuff i feel
like since the map is so big though
it's gonna take me a lot like me
personally it's gonna take me a long
time to like figure out like the best
way to play on it because it took me a
while to really figure out world veg
but
you know everything needs to take some
learning right
oh my gosh please weapon no i will
sorry i just ran through this whole half
and didn't see a single gun all right we
got it
got a wing man
i have not been doing well with the wing
recently i'll bag that
i
don't ever really
i'm close enough
to where it's it's literally impossible
to miss anything yeah
first blood already
if you flame out this soon yeah i think
they're on top of here wait is there a
lower portion there is a lower portion
to this oh
let's go check it out look at these bins
real quick and i'll be back
there's another blue down here
level two nice
gotta hop up here
oh it literally goes outside
oh man if i could put this 48 on my r99
i'd be sick
you can put on
the stream doesn't want to watch me
snipe i'll tell you that
i actually only recently just started
trying to like snipe more because i feel
like
the game's kind of leaning that way
where you need a sniper of some sort
especially with the size of this map but
i
i'm better with the charge rifle since i
get a little bit of time to like line up
my shot with the initial part of the
laser
longbows probably my second favorite
i saw them shooting at someone southeast
i think
this has perfectly landed
inside the door
oh this is hilarious
yeah they're over there behind the bin
that being i thought
oh yeah
oh
[ __ ]
oh they're here on the roof i think
brings closely smash just used her
whoa
i see what you mean now that's the spot
yeah
wait i guess if everybody's dead
you can't really scan their boxes
left
even heavy ammo
recharging my shields
how far do we have to go okay now 10
seconds at least
patrick
let me know when you guys want to fly
i'm almost there
go
get out of here
characters that have really like gray or
green or metal like
skins yeah you have an upper hand on
this type of map because
there's been so many times where
someone's been directly in front of me
but their skin is just matching the
environment and i see nothing
one extended energy i want heavy or
light
the champion fell
they did not deserve the title
real quick
wait where are they
i haven't even tried to kill any spiders
yet so
is this it
i am at 19. if i kill a few of them i
might be able to upgrade to a purple
oh yeah okay i'll save it for you then i
think it's oh yeah it's over here
let me out
oh there's a lot of them a lot of little
nests i'd say i probably don't need all
these
all right chad if you're scared of
spiders look away
[Music]
if there was a team in this choke i
would just break all these things to try
to like get them back
hell yeah
[Applause]
this gun is great
making contact with me nope that's not
what i wanted
something
oh see what i mean i did not see that
guy at all i kind of hurt him last
second
reloading
[Music]
setting a portal
charging up my shields
[Applause]
oh crap
oh being backed by that box
i didn't see that guy at all by the way
okay they started fighting each other
wonderful
now i have old but
i'm like i just need to get us to a spot
where we're no longer can we get oh
never mind they cheese they were a lot
closer than i thought
[Applause]
oh my goodness
it was a good idea have we gotten to
your old in time i think honestly i
don't think you guys would have made it
anyways because i was literally one shot
all right nice try
ggs that was fun lots of learning to do
for season 11 everyone lots of learning
okay
thank you guys for tuning in hope you
had a good time there's so much new
stuff in season 11 is
pretty interesting if you haven't played
in well i would definitely recommend
hopping back in because it's basically
brand new so you might like it more this
time around who knows um so i hope you
enjoy playing goodbye everyone
you know we we did our best we did our
best
all right see you guys later thank you
so much for joining us bye-bye
you